[Music]
hello everyone i'm grandmaster and
dennis
borosch and tonight we are going to
learn about the magnus causing variation
in the sicilian something i never
thought i'm going to say
but here we are so let's take a look at
the basic position where magnus carlsen
came up with an invention
so let's dive on in e4
c5 knight c3 d6
d4 already sort of a strange move
you wouldn't expect this you would
expect something
more like knight f3 knight f6 d4
takes takes and then we would get the
typical
nidorf structures now instead
white goes d4 immediately but this
does need a little bit of a background
so this game
the stem game is from 2018
between magnus carlsen versus
vojtasak from poland both of them are
grand masters very well known players
of course magnus is a world champion
now what actually is very interesting
that this event where they played
was held in shamkir azerbaijan in honor
of vugar gashimo and interestingly
enough
if you just put this into any of the
databases
and take a look who played this it was
geshema who played this
system c takes d4 queen takes d4
knight c6 and he played bishop b5 with
the idea of struck of transposing into
budapest
type of structures sometimes even
kind of thinking about playing an early
f4 as the knight does not really have to
go to f3 but this
transposes back to well-known waters
and this has been played multiple times
a bit a good success
by vugar and if you're not familiar with
it
vugargashima's legacy is a very very
strong
azeri player and was top 10
at some moment but sadly he passed on
early
due to bad health
and problems but
um in this game in honor of wugar
gashima whom kazan faced himself
multiple times
and knew how good he was he came up
with an original idea which of course
makes this
the magnus carlsen variation and that
move is
queen d2 but here i do want to take a
little detour
talking about naming openings and who
can name what
there is no rule actually in chess who
can name what
and what are the guidelines there are
plenty of lines
played by alekhine that is named after
the hotel
he played at and in fact alekhine
there is an anecdote that he was very
upset of the
fact that that sanatorium got
the credits and not the player playing
it
so interestingly enough there are
these ideas and ways of naming and
i did read the comments a bit before
of the smith mora line i showed earlier
and i do have to mention just because
you do not have
an internationally well-known title
doesn't mean you can't
invent openings and for that example i
have to give you
the sailor named captain evans
who was an inventor and a sailor mostly
but we all know him
for inventing the events gambit
was he titled no was he world champion
not even close yet he managed to play
one fantastic game and we have that
gumbet
to us all but back to the game
so queen d2 looks like a strange move
and i completely agree with the chat
what is this queen d2 move makes no
sense why is it played so
well for that you've got to understand
most of the times in these positions you
would
get dragons and 99.999 percent of the
time
you could not go b3 bishop b2 because
the knight being
loose on c3 and potentially attacked by
the
queen with queen a5 ideas
so that kind of begged the question can
white
play dragon style and sort of
create a fianchetto on the queen side
and i'd assume that was one of the ways
how
carlson and his seconds came up with
this idea of going queen d2 and b3
i mean queen d2 b3 and bishop b2 that
he'd love to
go there and play that direction having
a dragon kind of pressure
all along this diagonal is the idea of
b3 bishop d2 bishop b2 new
not at all but the whole concept of lose
losing quote-unquote time with the queen
go to d2
and leave the knight on g-fund is
completely original
and it is by all means magnus carlsen's
invention
never been played before this game
between carson and vojtessec
so queen d2 knight f6 the games that
we're going to
look at will mostly focus on knight f6
but there are other ways of playing with
g6 bishop g7 sometimes even bishop h6
but that won't be the topic of our
discussion
so queen d2 knight f6 the most natural
way of playing b3
and here voitasec goes for the classical
cheveningen structure
which i guess in some ways is a mistake
by black because it doesn't really take
advantage
of white losing time but is losing a lot
of time with moving the queen
from d4 to d2 and making
two moves just to develop this bishop on
the long diagonal
however once carlson manages to organize
his pieces
he is a little bit better than usual
the bishop on c1 actually has a
comfortable spot
and the king will be relatively safe on
the queen side
tucked away and then white's plan is
crystal clear
you can't really say the same thing with
black's position
in fact e5 would be an interesting
choice
as well and in fact let's play it in
this game
between fedoceive and nair
is very well known for being the coach
of the women's team of the russia
russians women's team and fido save is
of course an upcoming
young prodigy from moscow or at least
now residing in moscow but
our topic is e6 here bishop b2
and this is actually not that great
because it does
not kind of close off this bishop and
that bishop will become a monster as we
shall see
a6 long castles
b5 f3 and in fact if you just look at
the database
you'd see the who's who whoever played
this opening mostly the names you would
see
are high ranked and are super talents
namely aravind played this with white
against shashi kiran who was anand's
second
and he went for g4 b4 knight a4
castles g5 knight d7
h4 and you can see how blindingly easy
it is to play this position
you just throw all those pawns at your
opponent's king
while it is much much more difficult to
go against white's
queen side as there is this knight
blocking off
any potential a5 a4 moves with this
bishop
on b2 kind of consolidating the king's
situation
so not liking that and facing this whole
variation the first time uh voitasec
decides to go h5
not something unusual and not at all
something that we haven't seen before
this is one of the patented move
of the night or and even some other
lines kind of flirt with this idea
this is played in the taiman of two the
point is
black is trying to take away the g4
square
and that kind of hinders white's attack
mine can't really go f4 just yet
because that would run into b4 and then
the e4 pawn would fall
now in e4 openings if you lose the e
pawn you better have very good
compensation
otherwise in deep trouble
so this is the first moment i'm actually
curious if you guys can
catch the difference between a normal
sicilian
and the magnus cross and sicilian and
probably this is what
caught voitasec he didn't expect this
maneuver to show up
on the board so if you are watching live
or if you are watching later
it is your time to shine try to find
magnus carlsen's quite outstanding
maneuver
so just a little bit of a hint usually
you would have a knight on d4
and in that case you you have like a
limited amount of maneuvering
that you can do however here
the knight is not on d4 and it gives
some extra
options for magnus
exquisite is saying the knight is on g1
that's the main difference
that's a good starting point but just
noticing your pieces
will not make you successful you still
have to find
the way and you still have to find a
target
in your opponent's camp so first things
first you will have to go
and check out where you can latch onto
those targets
not many in black's position there is of
course the traditional d6 weakness
in the sicilian but it is surprisingly
hard to get come close to that one
the d6 pawns is actually hard to capture
bishop
a3 would run into b4 and that's
something
everyone wants to avoid including me
and astapada finds the right plan and
indeed it is knight h3
with the idea of getting the knight to
g5 normally this is
not even on the agenda because you have
a knight on d4
and there's no option doing this however
here magnus
has this extra option and with the pawn
already
on h5 this maneuver makes a lot of sense
you will not be able to drive that
knight away and the weakest link
on f7 is going to be crucial
knight h3 bishop e7 knight g5
and these are very very difficult cases
when you're
facing someone very well prepared with a
brand new
opening they know what they're doing
while you're
you know while you're sort of trying to
figure it out the first time
in your life of what's going on
and someone's asking whether f6 will be
an option not really because
apart from this d6 pawn this e6 pawn
needs some defenses if you ever play f6
this will be just way too weak and
let's redden that square because that's
going to be a big issue in that scenario
so voitasek plays h4
which in some ways i do not understand
i understand that he's trying to gain
some space but this movement itself
doesn't
really do anything positive for black's
position
probably something like bishop b7 would
be better at least
trying to get some development going
not that if y plays h4 um
it would make worse for white but
definitely
wouldn't change a whole lot in any case
so it goes h4
a little bit more ambitious trying to
kind of stop white from playing g3 or g4
but i don't think that magnus really
wanted to do that in fact with this
maneuver the e
pawn is defended i know it's a little
bit unorthodox way of defending the e
pawn
however it works and if it works it just
does work
and he goes f4 changes plans he doesn't
even go for g4 anymore
because that's the whole idea of his
opponent
voitusek is trying to play against that
but with this switch
he's actually gaining time not only does
he have pressure over
the f7 pawn but he's getting ready to go
for some
f4 e5 brakes bishop b7
and here you can see that h4 was
basically a waste of time
king b1 typical sicilian move you just
make sure
the king chills on the b file so it
doesn't run into some
tricky play with that rook c8
pressing on the knight on c3 and c2
rook c it was played so king b1 actually
is
justified and again as we're sort of
learning the magnus carlsen variation
where would you put the f1 bishop that
is probably the first thing you would
wanna
know not many options but two options
are still plenty when you have to make
one good decision
let's see bishop e2 considered what
about
bishop d3 i mean bishop b2 of course
is an idea but what about getting the
bishop to d3
both is actually legitimate um
but one of them is a bit more logical
than the other
so i see e2 will hit the g4 square well
for at the moment that is kind of
controlled so i don't think that's going
to be a big
issue bishop
e2 doesn't block the d file
that possibly could be a reason
if you want to break with e5 the e2
blocks the e file
not sure that the bishop if it goes to
e2 is the final destination
i saw in the chat and i agree this
bishop probably
wants to show up on f3 sort of
neutralizing that bishop
now i think both moves are playable
but magnus went for bishop e2 probably
with
the idea of getting the bishop to f3
pressing against that bishop
and sometimes e5 gains strength
if you go bishop d3 you are actually not
neutralizing
that monster of a bishop over there
queen c7 rookie one not even in a rush
to decide of going bishop f3
knight h7
knight takes h7 rook takes age seven
and voyage to his credit he's fighting
and he says hey i still would like to do
a
couple of exchanges if i can because in
that scenario
definitely he will get very very good
play
and with more exchanges the easier it is
to
sort of defend now
in this position magnus does the magnus
thing
he goes for something that is for sure
fire
good which might strike us
who love sacrifices as a bit jading
because we hope for some drama
on the chessboard however
you don't always have to be dramatic he
went for g4 here
which is completely fine and he is just
better in this position he
has no need to really complicate
matters but it does turn out that he
could go
the typical knight d5 sacrifice way as
the skin is still stuck in the center
black is bound to get destroyed
takes you have to take otherwise you
lose the pawn
or at least the bishop with big play on
that king
f5 and it definitely is going to
collapse on black
so knight d5 he takes e takes knight b8
and as shocking as it may seem if
they're bishop d3
a simple move black is just completely
lost
because if you go here white can just
take this pawn
here bishop f6 and there's absolutely no
way
of stopping the simple threat of rook
takes e7
and bishop takes e7 winning the queen
and it kind of shows that even if super
grandmasters
see these ideas or maybe they missed it
i'm not a hundred percent
sure but sometimes they would go for the
more cautious way if they feel
that they're already in the driver's
seat and probably he felt that
he has a great position why risk the
advantage
when the most natural move leads to a
slightly pleasant position for white now
this is
not necessarily the way we think who are
not super grand masters we would
love to do and play the more sparkling
move but
they are playing for the
title of a super tournament so for them
there is this added risk if they misplay
the position
it might be very costly so in this sense
i don't think g4
can really be condemned because he's
really just saying hey i'm better i have
no reason
to play risky chess
h6 h6 bishop f6 bishop d3
now as black already showed his hands he
makes sure everything's defended
and it goes for the simple g4 g5 plan
and this is actually kind of the beauty
of the magnus carlsen variation he's not
really trying um to do anything special
he just wants to
go all in with the attack on the king's
side and talk the king away
on the queen side with king c1 king b1
very simple play a bit cavemanish
in some respect you just go full on
for the attack rook h8 g4
immediately going for g5
knight d4 and this is actually the first
question
what to do here it seems like uh
white has some issues but magnus is not
just good at attacking he's pretty good
at defending
so let's channel our inner magnus
carlsen and try to find
the best defensive move right here
now of course with that we first have to
notice
what voitusack is setting up with this
move knight d4
what could be the potential issues that
we're facing
now for one thing the c5 is opening up
and that means this knot on c3 is a
little bit loose
so if we could stabilize that that would
be wonderful
for our hopes to win this game
now you might be asking me did magnus
see this move
prior for him playing g4 and my answer
is i'd think so
and the other threat is knight f3 so
there's two threats lingering
one of them is this one and the other
one is this knight f3
fork so the only task left is to stop
both there could be some tactical
sacrifices on b3 as well
the bishop takes c3 on tap
so i've seen some suggestions going rook
f1 or rook e3
the question is which one sort of
eyes the threats more
clearly we've got to make sure that that
c3 knight
is defended if it's not defended i'd be
worried about knight takes v3 sacrifices
yep that is correct rook e3
both eyeing the f3 square and that c3
knight
which makes knight takes b3 unplayable
because if takes
takes here queen takes c3 there is this
bishop b5 check
and the queen will drop on the c3 square
compare this to moving the rook to f1
there's knight takes a takes and bishop
takes c3
and there's no way of refuting it in
this case
when in the other one with rookie 3
this rook is ready to do a discovery
check
on the queen so these are those little
subtle ideas that make and break
a position and of course magnus carlsen
wouldn't be magnus carlsen if he
wouldn't find this
now again rook e3 not only stabilizes
the position but also stabilizes his
advantage
now he can go back to his old ways of
just throwing those
g5 and f5 pawns
the magnus variation yes it is and it is
straight from 2018.
this is in the sicilian so king f8
just trying to sidestep that trick and
here again a magnus cause and ask move
he is not afraid of exchanging pieces
if that consolidates the advantage
knight takes c2
root takes c2 bishop c3
takes takes and instead really
of going for the end game
he still realizes that there's a
difference between this king on b1
and on this square on f8
and the huge difference is that our king
is safe on b1
and that king on f8 is actually is in
some
danger so for magnus to exchange right
now
that's not something you should be doing
so you go screen e3
keeps the queens on the board and
continues on
with the hopes of running those pawns
down so you might be wondering
why was he doing these exchanges he just
didn't want to
sort of waste his time thinking of
defensive moves
and once he clarified all these threats
on the queen side he's moving on
to attack mode on the king side
rook c5
but with rook c5 black actually
makes quite a weakness in black's
position
what could be wrong with this move rook
c5
i mean it has a purpose don't get me
wrong it does take away and cover all
those important squares
however rook c5 has a downside
what could that downside be
the back rank issues exactly so before
with the rook on c8
it was sort of guarding all these back
ranks
but with that rook moving over to c5
that isn't really the case anymore
so that really begs the question how
could we get closer
to black's back rank
well if we go f5 we do try to open up
the position
but i don't see the background really
opening up with this move
we really don't have any any pieces on
the f file yet
so that's not likely to work out
now of course f5 g5 is something we
discussed but i think magnus noticed
that oh you change your plans well i
might change
the plans of my own as well
definitely you could try rookie one rook
h1 but it's a little bit
too long and the king might actually get
a chance to
run away and run towards the hills
running for their lives
however um we don't want to give that
luxury
so magnus did the immediate e5
with this rook on d1 sort of eyeing that
d8
square this makes a lot of sense now
this is still a sharp position it feels
kind of chill
for white because there's nothing going
on
on the queen side however if the dilly
dally a two
a bit too much we might run into some
issues
now black can't play d5 not only would
make this bishop french
which means it'll get very passive but
it also gives
this f5 idea and then we can just come
on in there and it's just gonna be a
brutal checkmate on d8
not to mention that this solid structure
will give a free hand for white to just
double up
on the f file so it took on e5
which probably made carlsen quite happy
ftx e5 rook h1 sort of
playing against these rook d8 ideas
take stakes and this is the moment
we need to take control how can why to
take
a final control of the position
it's not that the french defense is bad
it's just not good
so yeah let's try to find here magnus
carlsen's
very nice idea
so one of the ways of looking for moves
is to keep in mind which one of your
pieces
actually part of the game the bishop has
a job and
its job is to defend the c2 pawn so
there is nothing funny happening over
there
is the queen involved in the game i
would say so
the queen puts pressure can't even go
queen g5 later on
but there is a third piece that really
isn't contributing a whole lot and chess
is basically a group work therefore
rook h2 was played by carlson and with
this rook
infiltrating to the through the h
file attacking that h1 bishop black is
completely
losing because if you go here white can
just go check go queen g5 with a
decisive attack
so here instead
voitasec is trying to muddy waters
but it's too late
for muddy waters check and here
black resigned realizing there is no way
out
of course magnus isn't going to blunder
maiden one
if you go king f6 white can give a queen
f2 check
just to make sure everything's safe
after rook takes h1
it is game over because white is up a
healthy
extra piece and there's no hope
so after queen a7 check calls in one
do two blacks resigning so this was
actually the first
game ever played with the variation
the magnus crawls in the game versus the
voitusack and this
is the cause and variation so
guess who got inspired to play this
opening
none other than hikaru nakamura so we're
going to take a look
at his game versus mvl
let's see how he treats this position
so in this game knight f6
e6 the same thing happened and
hikaru as white will face a different
type of challenge
remember in the previous game or what we
usually call the stem game
magnus phase a6 and b5 but
sort of mbl is a bit sharper or feels
that
white is losing just too much time so he
may as well try to
complicate matters with d5
but the e5 actually has one downfall
with it that it creates a potential
target
on the e5 that is the dreaded isolated
pawn
which has a bad reputation but it's not
actually that crystal clear if it's bad
so he takes d5 he takes d5 long castles
and this is different though than your
usual isolated pawn
positions this king on c1
can run into some danger after some
potential queen a5
and bishop a3 as it actually is
going to be featured in this game um
the only issue that black is facing that
while black has the center control
might already has castle so mvl will
have to be
treading very carefully not to run into
troubles immediately
so it goes bishop e6 just bolstering the
d5 pawn
king b1 queen a5
now as all of you are a bit new to the
magnus carlsen variation or some of you
necessarily or how could
mbl the idea being countered how can we
counter this idea of bishop a3
if actually mvr could get bishop a3 in
there
castle his position wouldn't be as bad
at all
might be even better as there is like a
ready-made attack
over at the queen side
the question is how did
hikaru nakamura stop this plan
there are a couple of ways of doing so
but
it is always worth taking some time
checking the options
so yes indeed knight b5 is the move
played by hikaru
the point is not only is stopping this
idea of bishop a3
but pressing that queen on a5
the best part of this position is that
now after the exchange white gets
the most pleasant of the end games that
you can possibly get
there is a constant weakness on d5
not much play against white's pieces
the only issue white can be facing is
that the bishop
the knight and the rook on h1 is still
stuck in the first rank
but hikaru will make sure that's not a
problem
knight e4 typical mbl move he still
complicates things just to stay afloat
rookie two quite a calm move
he is making sure that's defended and
eventually he's going to
kick out the knight fact
the very next move he does takes that
knight out so we get this typical
isolated pawn
structure and i wonder what would be the
ideal setup for us
chat viewers any thoughts on what would
be
an ideal formation against an isolated
pawn
it's actually very important if you get
these type of positions
should you try to attack it or should
you try to block it
well yeah definitely if we could get
both of the knights or one of the
knights to d4 blocking is one way of
sort of
pressing down the opponent it's not that
you necessarily
going to win that pawn immediately but
in the long run
it is going to hold back black from
getting good counter play
so blockading and isolated pawn is much
stronger than attacking it
because oftentimes that just takes too
much energy
from your position so a6
knight d4 and this is the other thing
and the pleasant thing
when you're facing an isolated pawn
structure
any exchange you do you actually benefit
from that
because in the long run this will be a
target it might not be a target right
now
but it's going to be a target later on
definitely the knight maneuver of knight
hd knight f4 can
come to play but not quite yet that
takes d4
bishop takes d4 bishop c5
takes takes now if you would go knight
h3 here
that would be ill-advised you would
create a doubled pawn in your structure
with your pieces still kind of lingering
on f1 and h1
so hikaru's next move is a positional
extraordinaire
so let's try to find it it is very close
to the plans you guys already mentioned
and it is more of like strategic in
nature
can you spot hikaru's next move
so what will be the long-term plan for
hikaru if you can't find that
then you can actually kind of put the
jigsaw puzzle together
well it'd be amazing if we could
sacrifice in this position
but sadly we just don't have enough
material to do so
well our pieces are still scattered
they're too passive and this rook is
just in the way
so hikaru decides to move that rook to
d2
whole idea is he wants to get to d4
and if that knight can't sit in there
he's going to have a stable advantage
and not to forget about that it also
kind of moves out of the way that that
bishop
which is very important otherwise it's
very difficult to get the rook out
rookie eight knight e2 that's where
the knight is headed bishop f5
king b2 so he doesn't go knight d4
immediately because black could win some
time
and sort of it would tie down this
bishop on f1
so he decides to go king b2
circumventing
this in-betweener and he's planning to
go an id for just
a move later knight e6
and you can just see that both of these
players
understand and see the opponent's
concept
so therefore they're kind of playing
against each other's plans
now if knight d4 would happen now takes
takes rookie one and even though there's
a d
pawn weakness it doesn't really mean
that white is better
because the rook on h1 is just stuck
so here hikaru changes tac and goes
for a kingside expansion
and that is actually like the typical
super grand master play
you're not just focusing on one single
plan
if they're kind of trying to neutralize
that one plan you had you're looking for
another one
so you can distract them with that g4
bishop g6
h4 and he is starting to push mvl
back a little bit trying to play against
that bishop on g6
h6 bishop g2 may not be the best move
but it does develop and gets that kind
of loner look
on h1 into the game which is crucial in
endgames
to get a full involvement if possible
now at this moment it seems to me
that nvr got a little bit desperate
although it's somewhat understandable
if one manages to go something like
king c7 rook d1 and f4
this can get very annoying very quickly
as white has this annoying idea of
expanding with f4 f5
and there are some direct threats
against the d5 square
so here mvl does the typical
french defense not like the french
french defense
as the opening but he is going to muddy
waters before it gets too hot
rook d1 d3
c takes d3 and he makes sure that
yes he gives up the pawn but for that
he'll get some pressure on that pawn
with the pieces sort of
smothered because black has a little bit
more space right now
knight d4 knight takes d4 rook takes d4
and this is kind of the part of the game
that
kind of differentiates again between
super gms
and not so super gms super gms know how
to win these positions
even when it seems difficult to win
now should this be winning for him for
sure this should be winning
but it depends of how you go about it
that d-pawn is a weakness but it's also
strength
that's the reason why is sort of up and
ahead
it's an extra pawn and that should be
making white's life
easier so he goes king c3
and that is the typical grand master
that is super ground master move
he over defends his pieces and then
looks around
if he can devise a plan rook d8
h5 bishop h7 bishop f1
not a fan of bishop f1 but probably
hikaru wasn't a fan either
he just found no other ways of improving
this bishop
black still has some play because this
d-pawn is far
far from actually turning into a lady
anytime soon
but an extra pawn is an extra pawn
rook f4 bishop e2
and probably here envion makes a mistake
he goes too aggressive man maybe just
sitting and waiting would have been
better
why sitting and waiting would be better
because it's still not yet clear what
hikaru is attempting to do
in this position you can't really break
through yet
on the king side and that would be
something for hikaru to answer
but when he plays f5 that is mvl he
gives like a
clear sign that he's not afraid of
creating
targets on that side of the board and
of course hikaru immediately
brings his rook over pressing down the g
file
and eyeing that g7 pawn weakness
rook d7 g5
exchanging some pawns and also keep this
bishop locked in
and from a position where it seemed very
technically difficult
for hikaru he's actually gaining
momentum
and this is actually the part where you
kind of realize
chance is more of a sport than science
towards these critical phases
here nakamura just outsmarted mvl
um and sort of turned envia's style
against him as he should have had
possibly
sat and waited for hikaru to show his
hands
so f5 was probably a bit early and now
this g5 move is kind of strong
luke h4 takes 6
d4 and this is those
moments when you realize that hey you
can take that pawn that's not going to
be important
what's going to be important is your
bishop
being buried by that f5 pawn
okay h5 bishop c4
and this bishop from being
the sad sad person on g2
becoming the strongest man on the board
king c7 rook dg2 and look how tables
turned
from active positions that those rooks
and bishop had with pressing that d-pawn
suddenly it's white who has the active
pieces and a potential
passer d-pawn f4 bishop e6
taking away all those active
opportunities
and still kind of pressing that bishop
down
rookie 7 rogue g7
and guess what the reason that hikaru is
dominating
is because of that bishop over there
king d6
rook takes takes bishop c8 setting up a
double threat
of bishop b7 and rook g7 check
bishop f5 takes
takes check king f6
takes b7 so this is how he
actually played mvl
he made sure that everything was under
control
waited for the right moment to
turn it around and he got the active
pieces
now here black still has some hope of
survival
but is already kind of close to losing
so let's see what happened
h5 king c4 again a very important
move by hikaru he is planning
to support that d-pawn which is actually
not that
simple to do with this h5 pawn
because the king won't be able to carry
the h pawn this f1 is right there taking
away that square
so king g6
d5 h4 d6
that d-pawn is making a
run for it h3
rookie seven now when you're new to end
games
oftentimes you panic and you feel that
you must waste time stopping it
but the more you do this the better it
gets really
if the king is not supporting that past
pawn
after h2 it can get to rookie one and it
stops
that pawn from promoting
so this is just that typical race
you want to run down your pawn but you
don't really want to waste time
defending or going rook b8 and rook h8
so rookie 7 rook f8
now again hikaru does what has to be
done in the end game
he involves the king d5 rook h8
rookie one he's not afraid he knows
that the pawn won't promote by itself
there is that king that needs to be
involved in order to actually pose a
threat of winning the c1 rook
king g5 d7 and mvl
is trying but is just too distant
from getting there also not to mention
there is this rookie 8 idea now
sometimes we do miss these like little
moves
they are very very important if you can
cut off
your opponent's rook from controlling
that square
you should and then there is this
promotion
sometimes i see even grand masters miss
these
kind of in-betweener moves
that kind of wins the game of course mvl
is much too strong
to fall for that one goes rook
d8 king c6
king h4 and rook e8 wins now this
wouldn't necessarily
win if there wasn't some extra pawns for
hikaru but there is
and after this one white can
safely sacrifice this rook for the
h-bomb
while hikaru's king is gonna pick up
the rest and that is it
for the magnus cause and variation and i
really hope you enjoy
and you have a fun time playing it thank
you so much for watching
have a good day or night wherever you
are bye-bye
you